the world of the division is grounded in
reality an actual what-if scenario but
that scenario was based on a real
government drill that was actually
conducted to show how a biological
attack would screw up our society it was
called Operation dark winter that's
right a bunch of scientists and suits
got together in a room to talk about how
many people would die and what
governmental processes would break down
in a real world catastrophic events the
bioterrorist attack simulation was
conducted on jun 22nd and 23rd 2001 with
a simulated scenario starting with a
localized smallpox attack on Oklahoma
City that eventually spirals out of
control the simulation assumes that
there be such a huge rate of infection
that emergency responses would be
overwhelmed resulting in a huge amount
of civilian casualties it was used to
showcase issues that would occur in
society through such an event such as
the government killing people to keep
order in hiding the fact that their
rationing vaccines from the media good
to know there at least thinking about it
right